- So wait, you have a two year old now?
- I do.
- So how is that?
- Amazing.
- Are you exhausted?
Or you love it?
- I love it.
- You love every minute?
- I mean I,
I feel like it's the best thing that I've,
well, it is, I don't feel like it,
I know it's the best thing
I've ever done in my life,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and yeah it's the most,
it is really
- But wait two,
So like you don't have those
moments where you're like?
(Kelly mimics mad chuckling)
(Cameron laughs)
- I don't, I feel like as
a parent, that's your job
is to just be like okay, so
what are you feeling here?
How is it?
There's something there.
Kids are always just trying
to express a feeling,
- [Kelly] Yes!
- they're not actively trying to be bad.
They're just trying to-
- But when
they can't communicate,
they get so frustrated.
- [Cameron] Exactly,
so what is it?
- Yeah. I do my mom checklist.
Did she eat? Is she tired?
I'm like, what time is it?
You know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When was the last time
she ate? When did she,
you know, when is nap?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, and you
just kind of start there
and then you go, like, what just happened?
Is there something she's
trying to communicate to me?
And I just have, I feel like as a parent,
my job is to just help her
find the words to her emotions,
her experience, what she's going through,
and be able to help her identify that
and then move through it,
and what does she need from me
and what does she need from herself?
And is this something
- [Kelly] God you're like-
- she can take care of herself,
that she can self soothe
- Can we like talk
every week or-
- [Cameron] Yeah!
(Cameron laughs)
- Are you like naturally a patient person?
- Look it, I think that
because I'm an older parent
and I've already, I really
worked hard to get a child,
it's not something
that just happened to me-
- I'm not like a young parent!
I'm like...
- I know, but you know, I think
it's just a different thing
when I've also been
able, I'm very fortunate,
to have been able to
take the time to do it,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and be there with her.
And that's like just the hugest blessing
that I've had, yeah.
- That's great though.
You have like the most
amazing outlook on that.
- It's challenging, but
you know what's also
really imperative is to repair, you know?
Like if you do break, like blow up,
just to repair that and say,
oh my God, mommy lost (beep).
- Oh, that's what, yeah.
(Cameron laughs)
No, that's what,
no that's what, yeah you do.
- And just like,
I didn't mean to say that to you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- If I hurt your feelings
or if I upset you,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just want you to
know mommy's human too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I will say I'm lucky,
my kids are very communicative
to me in that sense.
Like, we're very open about...
I'm not afraid to say,
oh man, mommy messed up,
- [Cameron] Yeah.
- I should have handled it this way,
but you know how sometimes
you get so frustrated
you don't, that happens
to mommy too, you know?
I was like, so we just need
to do better, so we do that,
but it's...
You know what I think this
conversation deserves?
- [Cameron] What?
- Some of your wine.
- Okay!
(audience applaud and cheer)
(Cameron laughs)
- [Kelly] I think that
we should have a drink!
- Cheers to you, mommy!
- [Kelly] To being a really great mom!